petit chat mais reid est fade godard
claude à s'adhérer année mais pas telle
année bactéries trois élèves l'annnonce
de la victoire après 11 jours d'attentes
les applaudissements résonnent dans
l'enceinte de la knesset
hier soir benyamin nétanyahou n'a pas pu
compter sur un ralliement de dernière
minute la coalition hétéroclite mis sur
pied par yaïr lapid est approuvée par 60
députés
visage fermé le premier ministre sortant
observe les nouveaux membres du
gouvernement prêter serment à commencer
par celui qui va prendre la tête de
l'exécutif israélien pour les deux
prochaines années
l'une des figures de la droite
nationaliste naftali bennet années 20
les bannettes l'annnonce de ce
changement de gouvernement a provoqué
des scènes de liesse à jérusalem des
milliers d'israéliens s'étaient donné
rendez vous pour célébrer le départ de
benyamin nétanyahou
nous avons traversé quatre campagne
électorale mouvementée
[Musique]
nous attendions ce moment je suis sans
voix
[Musique]
nous devons comprendre que nous avons le
pouvoir et le privilège de faire bouger
les choses et pas seulement de rester à
l'écart en espérant que les choses
s'améliorent mais faire quelque chose
agir pour y arriver
à peine investi le nouveau gouvernement
s'est réuni pour présenter les grandes
lignes de son programme
côte à côte naftali bennett et yaïr
lapid se disent prêts à gouverner
ensemble malgré leurs divergences pour
que ce gouvernement fonctionne nous
devons tous observé de la retenue et
mettre à distance les aspects
idéologiques ce qui a fondé ce
gouvernement c'est l'amitié et la
confiance est ce qui va maintenir ce
gouvernement et l'amitié et la confiance
si nous savons comment nous faire
confiance et nous soutenir mutuellement
et travailler ensemble pour que cela
fonctionne cela fonctionnera selon
l'accord de gouvernement naftali bennet
passera le relais à la tête de
exécutif à yaïr lapid dans deux ans mais
les deux hommes savent que leur
coalition allant de la gauche à la
droite nationaliste reste fragile
les huit partis qui la composent vont
devoir s'entendre sur de nombreux sujets
brûlants conflit avec les palestiniens
question du nucléaire iranien ou encore
relance économique post pandémie autant
de sujets qui apparaissent comme les
principaux défis de ce cabinet l'une de
ses premières décisions pourrait déjà
s'avérer crucial le maintien ou non
d'une marche organisée par la droite
radicale ce mardi à jérusalem le hamas a
déjà menacé israël de représailles si ce
rassemblement se produisait